welcome back to new rock stars i'm
whitney van laningham and today we're
diving head first through the gate back
into the upside down this time armed
with a spiky trashcan lid and the sweet
pure sound of metal flowing through our
veins or kate bush depending on how you
feel about metallica
here's a breakdown of everything you
might have missed while ugly cry
screaming at vekna during stranger
things season 4 volume 2. chapter 8 papa
opens inside a memory of what happened
in the rainbow room the day that 11
thanos dusted one slash henry vecna
sending him to an alternate dimension
this time when we hear papa ask what
have you done it turns out that he
doesn't believe 11 was responsible for
the rampage instead he asks her this
because as we find out later on he was
angry that l had banished his favorite
experiment even after witnessing the
carnage brenner was still
single-mindedly focused on protecting
henry soley because of his potential as
steve tries to wake nancy up in the
upside down the other teens are
frantically searching through eddie's
trailer for any cassette tapes that
might bring her back to hawkins although
robin insists that examples of real
music that nancy will respond to include
madonna blondie bowie and the beatles
eddie screams while holding iron
maiden's piece of mind cassette that
meddle is real music hell yeah eddie
teller eddie's bedroom actually has even
more metal easter eggs than i realized
he has a poster from anthrax's fistful
of metal album a tracklisting tour
poster for the death metal band massacre
a judas priest defenders of faith poster
a slayer flag and a poster for creator's
endless pain and he also has a couple of
pretty sick vintage blacklight posters
from the 70s my favorite decor in his
room however is the art tornado from his
advanced dungeons and dragons manuals
from the player handbook we have a magic
user studying and from the monster
manual we have a fighter facing down a
horde of monsters over in russia joyce
takes care of hopper's demogorgon wound
when he asks her how she's getting along
with murray joyce replies he's the star
ski to my hutch starsky and hutch was a
1970s cop show featuring police officers
david michael starsky and kenneth
richard hutch hutchinson as the group
searches for a way out of the prison and
away from the monsters and guards they
next enter a room where more demidogs
and demogorgons at varying stages of
development are floating in tubes filled
with yellow liquid presumably in a
comatose state this scene is a direct
pull from 1997's alien resurrection
which starred winona ryder alongside
sigourney weaver ellen ripley finds a
lab full of xenomorphs stored in similar
yellow vials where the us government has
been harvesting aliens to study them and
this is where i started screaming at my
tv because unlike ripley joyce and
hopper don't immediately douse all of
them in fire scarier however is when
they stumble upon the mind flayer's
smoky particles trapped inside a glass
cell alive joyce slater tells the group
that this means that a gate must
currently be open in hawkins based on
her knowledge from season three that the
mind player is only active when a portal
between dimensions is open brenner and
owens bring eleven back to consciousness
after her experience inside her darkest
memory when she gets up she uses her
newly reinstated powers to lift the ten
thousand pound nina into the air a nod
to the scene in empire strikes back when
luke levitates his ship out of the muck
and dagobah will finally reveals the
painting he's been working on for months
it's a drawing of the party fighting a
red three-headed dragon in season two
mike reveals each member's d d class
listing himself as a paladin will is a
cleric dustin is a bard lucas is a
ranger and l is a mage however this
painting seems to depict their season 1
classes from their og campaign featuring
will the wise as a wizard rocking robes
like his cosplay in season three in the
ancillary hawkins middle school yearbook
the other boy's character names are
revealed too dustin plays a dwarf named
nog lucas is a fighter called sundar the
bold and mike supposedly has a dm pc
called tear when jonathan glances in the
rearview mirror he can tell that will's
pep talk to mike about 11 always needing
him in her life was actually about his
feelings for mike as well where 11 is
different and feels like a mistake
because of her superpowers will
experiences those feelings too due to
his sexuality as we all know it's been
heavily implied that will is gay and
clearly has unrequited feelings for his
best bud to help mask his feelings as l
will says that elle commissioned the
painting even though she explicitly said
earlier in the season that she didn't
know what he was painting back at the
lab brenner explains to 11 that he
always believed that henry was out there
hiding in the darkness and that although
he didn't know for sure that he was
still alive he's certain now he also
tells her that with every victim he
takes henry is chiseling away at the
barrier that exists between our worlds
and demonstrates his impending
destruction by breaking a pencil this
analogy reminds me of the one that mr
clark performed for the boys on bikes at
will's funeral when they asked him to
explain how multiversal traveling could
theoretically work in season one when
vechna releases nancy she tells the
others what he showed her hawkins in
ruins and a monster with a gaping maw
alongside an army of other monsters a
fact to remember in the very last scene
of the finale max realizes that the four
chimes of beckness clock represent the
four victims he needs to kill in order
to open the gate like will he can now
feel his presence fighting demogorgons
has a nasty habit of making you snacky
but one cannot battle with waffles alone
you need a tasty variety to roll nat 20
on one of these suckers and that's where
baksu comes in if you have not heard of
boksu oh man the whole new rockstars fam
are big fans let me fill you in baksu is
a fancy japanese snack subscription they
source rare snacks from all across the
country and even partner with family
businesses to make their own signature
things all of this gets curated and
delivered under a new theme every month
okay now i'm going to show you some of
my snacks so this is the box as you can
see there are so many i can dig in this
thing so this month is the manatsu
fruits oh my god there's a little haiku
on the back the warmer weather has a
seeking adventure vacation awaits that's
really rad i like it okay this one is
called a melon boucher
whoa cookies oh and it smells so good
it's like a bun and i'm gonna eat it
that's delightful it's kind of like a
it's like lemony sort of oh man sorry
i'm just gonna stand here and eat this
because it's good
we've been receiving these boxes for a
while now and we all love them the whole
office gets stoked during the unboxing
plus every time you get your boxu in the
mail you can feel good knowing that
you're supporting small family
businesses all the way in japan if you
want to try some rare japanese snacks
with us and support the channel click
the link in the description and use code
rockstars to get 15 off your order
interestingly the number four has been
staring us right in the face the entire
time hinting at this realization from
day one not only does vecna's reveal
happen in season 4 the whole crew is
separated across the world in four
groups hopper joyce and murray in group
1 will mike jonathan and argyle in group
2 the hellfire hawkins gang in group 3
and 11 brenner and owens in group 4.
also if you check out the poster for
this season it's divided into four parts
connected by four cracks with a gate in
the middle keep that imagery in mind
because it comes back into play in the
finale as hopper joyce and murray break
out of prison you can see a drawing of a
penis hung up on the wall of the russian
guard's shack i'm sorry but throwing
random dick art in the background of a
serious scene might be my favorite
easter egg all season as they escape
highlights fire by the red army choir
plays at max's the hellfire club plans a
trip to the weapons store called warzone
featuring a knockoff rambo as their
mascot max loans eddie the michael myers
mask from her halloween costume in
season two so that he can covertly steal
his neighbor's winnebago this rv has a
lot of interesting stickers like
yosemite sam from looney tunes an
anti-welfare sticker reading can't fetum
breed them and another that says america
love it or leave it then there's
stickers from various destinations like
the grand old opry in nashville
tennessee and six flags inside there are
two stickers one that reads president
reagan bringing america back and the
second that reads keep your city clean
eat a pigeon as steve drives off up
around the bend by creedence clearwater
revival plays in the back seat max tells
lucas her plan to hide in the light when
vecna comes for her without even knowing
about elle's conversation with brenner
about one hiding in darkness she
instinctively knows that she'll have
more power in her happy memories when
lucas asks if he's there in any of her
best memories she says that's
presumptuous of you which is the same
thing she says to him and destin when
they first meet in season two that's
presumptuous of you
us
that's a good thing right as steve and
nancy also talk about steve's dream to
explore the country with his six little
nuggets in tow fire and reign by james
taylor plays at the war zone rock and
roll hoochie coo by rick derringer plays
the bulletin board at the front of the
store is plastered with wanted posters
for the hellfire club even more
horrifying however is when robin sees
her crush vicky making out with some
dude in a purdue jacket robin flees but
not before we get a glimpse of vicky's
adorable molly ringwald 16 candles-esque
outfit inside the lab owens and 11
decide it's time for her to leave
training behind to fight vecna and save
hawkins but brenner insists that she
stay yet another empire strikes back
parallel luke left dagobah against the
wishes of yoda in order to save his
friends as well after elle calls brenner
out for every lie mistake and bad choice
he's made such as making a murderous
psychic a child caretaker he stabs her
in the neck with a sedative when she
wakes up elle has a shot collar on her
neck just like the one brenner put on
two as punishment in episode vii after
lieutenant sullivan's team breaches the
nina project lab he gives the orders
quarter in search by twos hicks take the
upper level these orders are directly
lifted from a line said by lieutenant
gorman and aliens as brenner lay dying
after 11 takes down the sniper's
helicopter in one of the most badass
moments of the show he begs 11 to
understand that he only wanted to help
her she ignores his request and leaves
his manipulative ass in the desert to
rot along with the symbolic and literal
shackles he used to control her the
camera spins out as brenner dies in a
crucifix pose first representing the
christ-like way he sees himself then
inverts to depict him as an antichrist
figure whose hubris brought vecna's
wrath into our world but the camera
continues to spin because as vecna later
points out brenner is neither savior or
monster he's only a man as the episode
ends the song from part two's trailer
worlds apart by journey begins to play
showing that not only is the upside down
a separate world from hawkins this is
the first time in the entire series that
the characters won't be meeting up to
share intel and fight alongside each
other yet even though these characters
are worlds apart they will still find a
way to fight the upside down together
while yuri tinkers with katinka murray
can be faintly heard in the background
telling antonov that he'd like it in
indiana and that he has a stoic clint
eastwood vibe the only shirts available
in the peanut butter smuggler's stash
are hulk hogan merch like the cab driver
from chapter 2 yuri's buyers are also
apparently big hulkamania fans after
years of waiting we finally get to see
joyce and hopper smooch after learning
that 11 will and jonathan have gone to
fight monsters yet again hopper decides
that he joyce and murray will break back
into the prison and kill the mind flayer
to give the kids the upper hand murray
responds nervously this is dirty dozen
stuff referencing the 1967 war movie
about a group of soldiers convicted of
terrible crimes that were sent on
suicide missions just before d-day not
only was the dirty dozen based on a real
group of rule-breaking demolition
specialists instructed to operate behind
deadly enemy lines called the filthy 13
the story was also inspiration for the
suicide squad while the hellfires map
out the four phases of their plan to
stop vecna the california crew pulls
into a gas station to try to book 11 a
last-minute plane ticket to hawkins find
time to let me know by free beer is
playing eleven sees a triple a billboard
depicting a family with a little girl
writing piggy back on her mother not
only does this trigger the memory of
traveling into her own mother's mind and
seeing billy's mother inside his
memories she also realizes that she can
piggyback through max's memories to
fight vechna hilariously the character
that argyle and jonathan talk into
letting them turn the shop's deep
freezer into a sensory deprivation tank
for a girl with telekinetic powers is
named argyle 2.0 according to the
credits mike grabs sunglasses out of the
van to make 11 a pair of blackout
goggles and when he does you can see the
car's greatest hits cassette tape on the
dashboard while preparing to enact phase
one of their plan at the old creel house
lucas asks max to go to the movies with
him in response max draws a picture of
the two of them holding hands sharing a
tub of popcorn when she turns off her
headphones and calls out to vecna max
yells what are you waiting for just like
jennifer love hewitt's character julie
screams in 1997's i know what you did
last summer while egging on the killer
to attack although hopper joyce and
murray managed to easily pass back
through the prison gates murray says i
don't know jim i got a bad feeling about
this mirroring han solo's line from a
new help when they climb back into the
tunnel hopper leaves the lid off the
peanut butter jar so to speak which
makes me think that it's possible that
one of these monsters or even a piece of
the mind flayer could have also broken
out after testing out eleven's cool new
shades she and argyle forced mike to try
his first slice of pineapple pizza if
you listen closely you can hear him
shouting i am not a dog i am not a baby
and finally you're right it's good as
will and jonathan have a heart to heart
40 miles bad road by dwayne eddie plays
l climbs into the freezer to help max
fight becnus slash henry telepathically
max flashes backwards through a series
of memories from the past three seasons
elle follows her landing in max's
earliest memories of skateboarding
although she tries to hide in the light
alex is confronted with the memory of
billy begging to be let out of the sauna
from season three but she manages to
land herself in the memory of the
snowball dance from the season 2 finale
atop his trailer in the upside down
eddie begins to play the most metal solo
of master of puppets ever to exist in
this or any other world before he shreds
he dedicates the show to chrissy at the
snowball table decorations and balloons
begin exploding with blood and the
flowers begin to wilt and die those
exploding balloons were pulled from the
it mini series when adult ritchie is
tormented in the library by its bursting
blood balloons and of course the dance's
blue aesthetic tainted by blood looks
similar to the prom and carry the
streamers are also reminiscent of a
spider's web signifying that max has
fallen into spider lover vecna's trap
and killing ground the turntable is once
again playing every breath you take by
the police as it was in season two but
this time the song changes to ella
fitzgerald's dream a little dream of me
aka victor kriel's vekna song if you
look at the record it still shows that
the police's album synchronicity is
rotating back at the skate park eleven
sees a table from the snowball with a
record player on it and before she joins
max in that memory she sees the mind
flayer looming over hawkins inside the
current memory she's in just like it was
hovering above hawkins high in season
two bekna catches up to max and reveals
that he has known their plan all along
and that he's actively killing her loved
ones across both dimensions 11 fights
back but vekna manages to transport her
and max to his red mindscape where he
keeps his victims bodies and she's
strung up by tentacles next to chrissy's
corpse their conversation shows the vast
differences between their two characters
while eleven tries to use empathy for
their shared trauma to reach henry henry
has rejected humanity henry reveals more
of his history to l including that as a
child he once drew a nearly identical
mind flayer as the one that will drew in
season two the fact that both of these
characters drew this creature decades
apart is pretty freaky and makes me
think that next season will dive further
into the parallels and connections
between these two when henry first
entered the upside down its rocky
terrain was devoid of human life instead
it was home to monsters which is how he
stumbled upon the mind flayer's
shapeless smokey form using his powers
he gave the mind flayer its spidery
shape and began his plot to destroy
mankind although vecna manages to break
max's arms legs and eyeballs elle blasts
him backwards in time to stop him from
finishing her off empowered by mike's
words of love and encouragement the
tentacles drop robin steve and nancy
robin says i don't believe in a higher
power or divine intervention but that
was a miracle which sounds extremely
similar to jules's explanation of divine
intervention and miracles to vincent
after narrowly avoiding being shot in
1994's pulp fiction as you all know maya
hawk's mom uma thurman also starred in
this movie as running up that hill by
kate bush begins to play eleven uses her
powers against one and murray fire
blasts the demogorgon's hopper and joyce
trap wounding the hive mind when hopper
decapitates the last monster standing
the sword he uses is conan the barbarian
sword from the 1982 movie when steve's
molotov cocktail hits vecna's
unconscious body in the upside down his
form within the red mindscape is
consumed by black smoke nancy channels
her inner sarah connor and shotguns
vecna until he flies out the window
landing on the street below still
burning when they run outside later his
body has disappeared this mirrors the
ending of 1978's halloween when michael
myers is also shot and falls backwards
out of a window like
myers's body is missing setting up his
return in future sequels in a death
scene even more heartbreaking than bob
newhart's eddie passes away from his
demobat wounds during his final
conversation with dustin when it's cold
i'd like to die by moby plays as he
tells him he loves him before fading
away eddie also has a bat tattoo on his
arm which is how i should have known
that he was doomed from the start
equally traumatizing however is max's
deathbed she cries and screams that she
isn't ready to die as lucas holds her
when the clock strikes four times robin
steve and nancy realize that max is dead
and the gate where her body lay begins
to crack open triggering the other three
gates to open as well forming a giant x
through hawkins remember that poster
this is like a gigantic version of that
as the portal hits jason it splits his
body in two which is kind of ironic
because that's how he described
hangovers to lucas after their
basketball victory party eleven uses her
powers and her memories with max from
season three to bring max back to life
and we flash forward to two days later
in max's hospital room lucas has hung
her drawing of the two of them above her
bed and is reading a copy of stephen
king and peter straub's the talisman
this story actually has a ton of
parallels to stranger things including a
boy called jack who can travel between
dimensions and has the ability to remain
alive in another of his altar's bodies
even if he dies in a different universe
the passage lucas reads max is about
jack encouraging another character to
open their eyes and i think that these
two plot similarities might give us a
hint of what to expect for season five
when elle visits her in the hospital she
takes max's hand closes her eyes and
enters her mind although we don't see
her find max in the darkness on this
trip it's important to note that eleven
now has the ability to travel into
someone else's consciousness without a
sensory deprivation tank a blindfold or
static noise kicking one's ass has made
her stronger the hawkins high gym has
been turned into an emergency shelter so
rob and steve and destin volunteer to
help while robin makes pb j's with vicki
who is a fan of fast times after all
dustin makes his way to the missing
person's bulletin board where eddie's
uncle is replacing his missing flyer
because someone has drawn devil horns
and a pentagram on the old one also on
the board is a flyer for a missing woman
named janet howard who disappeared at
bradley's big buy the store where eleven
stole eggos in season one implying that
the market was one of the portal's
casualties dustin comforts mr munson
with stories of eddie's kindness even in
death and gives him the guitar pick
necklace that eddie used to play his
final concert chrissy
this is from y'all at hopper's cabin
that was wrecked by the mind flayers
meat form in season three the kids begin
to clean their new hiding spot for 11.
argyle says i mean i get we gotta hide
supergirl and all but this isn't exactly
a fortress a solitude man referencing
superman's headquarters in dc comics in
the house you can spot an old box of
eggos on the counter and the game shoots
and ladders on the coffee table a call
back to the kinds of board games she
used to play with hopper as she enters
her room she once again leaves the door
open three inches and finds the empty
coke bottle that she and max used to
play spin the bottle with her powers
back in season three when she reunites
with hopper she tells her dad that his
hair looks [ __ ] call back to the
words she learned back in season two
unfortunately the buyers in the hopper's
reunion is cut short when the upside
down spores begin to fall from the sky
if you recall it was established back in
season two that long-term exposure to
the spores makes humans incredibly sick
so the fact that it's rapidly spreading
across hawkins and eventually the globe
is really not looking good for the
town's future like the pumpkin vines
that rotted when the upside down leaked
from hawkins lab into merrell's pumpkin
farm the field of flowers behind
hopper's cabin is quickly consumed by
the upside down from the gates and
hawkins rise numerous clouds of dark
smoky particles that look similar to the
mind player's original form before vecna
molded it into a spider the song that
plays out the credits is spellbound by
susie and the banshees the lyrics of
which say following the footsteps of a
ragdoll dance we are entranced
spellbound like vecna and metallica
warned 11 even though they've found
comfort in their victories his
unstoppable plan is already in motion
this season's ending mirrored empire
strikes back in more ways than just 11
and luke both abandoning their training
to save their friends episode 5's ending
also shows our star wars heroes defeated
but mostly alive as they band together
in preparation to continue the fight the
duffer brothers even confirmed in an
interview with the rap that season 5
would be a lot like return of the jedi
but that we'd have to wait until we
finished season 4 to understand why like
max in her coma han solo is also frozen
in carbonite and the opening of return
of the jedi largely centered around his
rescue and revival as i suspect season 5
will for max unlike luke skywalker
however eleven has both of her original
hands intact and delivered a hefty blow
to vecna while luke was left handless
lightsaberless and clinging to a space
antenna i've got a good feeling that if
luke can come back and save the galaxy
from his daddy issues eleven's got
vecna's defeat on lock follow me on
instagram and twitter whitneypuppy
follow new rockstars subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you